in the lobby of Ramsey solutions William
and Marissa are with us hey guys how are
you crazy how are you where do you guys
live awesome welcome to Nashville and
here to do your debt-free scream yeah
yes complete with t-shirts pre-printed
for the occasion sell intense and Dave
what's my homie got a lot of compliments
in Nashville on it fine how much debt of
you guys paid off
we've hit about $94,000 how long did
that take you seven years and making
what kind of money during that time 35
grand
Wow and after right after we paid it all
off then it bumped to like 80 work hard
and good things happen yeah we pretty
much had a lot of up-and-down moving
around trying to find a job and we had
the problem a lot of people that you're
talking to this hour didn't have which
is we took out loans a lot of this was
student loan we have a 94 yeah and we
had too much I was stating loans almost
all of it oh wow
yeah we had a little bit just a tiny
little bit in credit card and a tiny bit
on like a car note when we had to have a
laptop and I'm one of those tech guys
now so what are your degrees in I have
many education in education chemistry
and chemistry okay and your household
income was 35 and now it's 80 yeah yeah
for seven years after graduation
yet fluctuated a little we went up as
high I think 45 when I was looking at
our taxes but it was pretty much 35 the
whole time and what happened seven years
ago that took you guys on this journey
he doesn't remember it we not the
marriage but we were driving down to see
our family on a vacation for Christmas
and he's like I found this guy on the
radio we should listen to it I
downloaded it on the iPod and for six
hours we listened to your show oh and so
I was like okay that's it we're let's do
this forever
I was a grad student I was sick of being
broke
that's bad enough yeah pretty much we
just said okay
I'm in my last year master's degree
we're gonna pay it we're not gonna take
out any more loans and so we looked at
each other and said what can we sell to
pay off this last you know semester I
have and that started the whole process
and then seven years later a new your
stand yeah that's a long time yeah we
actually this is our honeymoon this is
our honeymoon we came to Nashville there
you go to do a debt-free scream at
Dave's office Wow very cool well
congratulations you guys for sticking
with it so since we're talking about
this I've changed subjects for a second
we're talking about going to college
debt-free if you had it to do over what
would you do different we tell all of
our siblings anyone that will listen in
high school
anyone at all that is looking down the
barrel I work with a lot of teenagers
and and some like odd jobs that I do and
I'm like listen don't take out loans I
don't care what you have to do sell
things work all the time the years
before you go work over summers I we
like we we live in a tourist town so I'm
like get a job during the summer work
your butt off but don't take out a loan
because you're gonna regret it and we
have a lot of friends that do yeah how
much can you borrow well how much will
you give me that's not how it works
you were good at at seven years seven
years of slavery will wake you up to
that fact forever yeah yeah you guys
will never go back never what do you
attribute the key to getting out of debt
what do you tell people the secret to
getting out of debt is intensity you've
got to be on fire on purpose and it's a
long time to be on fire for us but there
were there were you know those times
when you're just like well we're just
not gonna have a car for six months and
we live in the middle of rural New York
so we took a bus that only came into
town two times a day for six months
going to work without a car and lived in
a studio apartment with a dog and just
basically used clothes forever until we
couldn't anymore and sewed the holes in
them if we needed to and it's like the
tuna fish story right we hot dogs and
onions and I promise you can eat on a
budget it is cheap if you eat hot dogs
and onions Wow yeah that's scary but I
didn't look like this I've been eating a
lot better so
about 20 pounds lighter it's a good bin
scheme just diet
Wow well congratulations you guys thank
you waiting and waiting and all of our
family they weren't actually all
supportive they kind of thought we are
nuts but now we have money yeah
and all of our friends are seeing your
progress and they're like wow tell me
about this budget like what do we do how
does it work just everything happening
yeah
it's amazing once you start winning
people want to know how you did you know
when you're driving a jalopy
alright everyone wants to do it when
you're doing well alright William and
Marissa Albany New York $94,000 paid off
in seven years making thirty five now
making 80 counting down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
Oh
you guys awesome job
proud of you very very well done
you